donc là vous avez la version avec le x5
et qui est disponible en couleur grise
et là c'est la version avec le on est à
new york
voilà retour du cs plutôt cool quelques
jours à new york histoire de visiter te
faire plaisir plus de vous faire plein
de contenus voilà je vous pose sur une
espèce de lit assez instable donc c'est
ça bouge beaucoup et je trouve donc
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un produit
que j'ai vu quand j'étais aux crs dorsaz
les petits bonbons latrèche et quand je
viens aux états unis j'adore voir ça dr
pepper
c'est très chimiques mais alors ça alors
on va parler aujourd'hui du noir
dînatoire est sorti huawei c'est le
macbook 13 pouces que je trouve assez
cool format très compact et surtout et
là où c'est très intéressant c'est un
vrai concurrent du macbook air d'apple
il ya différence notable ces faits ne
pas être sur mac os mais d'être sur
windows d'ici ça c'est une autre
histoire
je vous ramène au cs je vous ramène à
las vegas mais juste avant je vous
montre quelques images détournées
aujourd'hui pour un smartphone que j'ai
testé c'est le tracteur x4 de crosse
coll
c'était ma vidéo test du smartphone
aujourd'hui si la journée a crapahuté et
j'ai vu plein plus cool joubin type en
haleine tout le monde de trois images et
après direction vegas
[Musique]
comme entre un smartphone qu'on n'y a
pas d'europe c'est ça c'est le make 20
x il est juste énorme sans enterrement
présent à regarder le format est
complètement fou et je pense qu'elle a
été le marché européen n'est pas encore
prêt alors d'une espèce de fable est
comme ça monsieur on ne vous attendait
prend 7,2 pouces de diagonale vous
rendez compte que le galaxy s samsung
galaxy x un écran de 5,5 pouces ça veut
dire que ça va à peu près la même chose
mais qui se plie en termes de format
c'est beaucoup plus compact jeu
permettra peut-être de faire venir des
très grands écrans comme ça sent quand
tu reviens dans votre poche ça c'est
hallucinant non les sur le stand de
huawei directement au sol est gelé les
embêter pour faire débrancher la larme à
partir en courant rec preuve le nouveau
netbook 13 pouces qui un petit blanc
d'une macbook air d'apple qui est
franchement assez cool très compacte
je pense que là dessus huawei fait belle
montée en gamme que ce soit au niveau
des pc portables que ce soit au niveau
des smartphones
c'est franchement est affolant c'est pas
une bête de puissance on a une telle
core i5 ou i7 dessus on a 8 giga drame
on est du stockage en ssd soit 256 go de
stockage soit 512 vient de stockage qui
coule c'est que l'écran est complètement
tactile ça c'est franchement bien au nom
d'écran de 2160 par 1440 pixels
au niveau graphique c'est une nvidia
geforce et mixant 50 avec de gibert ram
gddr5 est intéressant c'est que vraiment
dire qu'il ya ce matin concurrence
directe avec le macbook air d'apple on
sait qu aurait donc vraiment vraiment
aux gardes au niveau des smartphones
mais également au niveau des ordinateurs
portables est assez compact il est assez
fin vous avez là un port usb type c vous
avez exactement le même de l'autre côté
il se recharge en usb type si vous
l'avez là vous avez gardé l'appli diack
ça c'est pas mal
il n'y a pas beaucoup de choses pour le
connecter donc là vous avez la version
avec le x5 et qui est disponible en
couleur grives et là c'est la version
avec le i7 qui est dans une espèce d'un
petit violine qui est très sympathique
ma foi plutôt pas mal alors ce qui est
très pratique là-dessus voyez c'est que
c'est pas des dégâts qui sont très très
gros seins c'est assez compact néanmoins
vous avec un trackpad qui est assez
grand ça c'est bien vous avez si un
capteur d'empreintes digitales vous
échappe une petite seconde ça dérouille
c'est plutôt pas mal après ce qui est
sympa c'est que vous avez ici up la
petite caméra cachée juste la bombe ont
trouvé un peu comme faisant reid apple
ça c'est pratique
il est quand même relativement fin
autour de touche pas mal ça vaut pas les
claviers des macbook pro comme toi j'en
ai un match tant que clavier macbook pro
est quand même vachement sympa après on
n'est pas serein et qu'ils ont du mal
vous promet vraiment du macbook air
donc bon voire il faut aussi prendre un
peu de recul par rapport à ça le
trackpad plutôt pas mal
je pense que cet ordinateur peut
vraiment être une bonne solution pour
tous ceux qui veulent quelque chose de
compacts qu'ils veulent quand même chose
à tous péké notamment sur le i7
vous avez plus sur lui cinq si vous
voulez plus quelque chose je dirais pour
avoir de la bureautique un peu standard
et si vous avez un peu plus de
performances qui sauve qui va durer un
peu plus dans le temps avec un peu plus
de fluidité
je pense que le i7 peut être pas mal
pour faire du montage vidéo ça va être
quand même vraiment trahi parce que
n'avait que 8 giga octet drame
mais pour faire tomber un photoshop un
peu light dessus sans trop de calques
franchement ça ira elle tombe
forcément sur windows dix à la dernière
j'ai pas si vous souvenez la marque
furio furieux avait misé sur le haut
c'est es un énorme camion qui était en
fait un camping à énorme avec un
hélicoptère sur le toit bon cette année
ils sont dix c'était marrant c'est assez
rigolo
il ya un peu plus de bois ils ont
carrément fait revenir la croisière
s'amuse
vous avez un énorme bio de luxe donc ce
que je vous propose d'aller faire un
petit tour
ce truc est complètement hallucinant
travail on y va c'est parti cela rompt
pas les prendre un petit bain dans le
jacuzzi
hu
si canapé pour se détendre et se
regarder une petite série pas mal la
poste de pilotage
là le capitaine peut se mettre là c'est
assez incroyable très glissant fait
attention petit champ on s'est très cosy
petit miroir c'est très très petit avec
votre télé là c'est très sympa et là on
a la grande chambre avec la télé a cru
stella directement en miroir ça à
regarder ici à quoi la salle de bain
regardez là je peux piloter ma chambre
mettre la musique je peut l'arrêter sur
le miroir la jacquerie accès au pilotage
le truc qui est juste hallucinant et là
on a une deuxième chambre ici qu'est-ce
qu'on la voit la très grande chambre
donc on a quoi ça glisse donc y en a
quatre chambres c'est la deuxième grande
chambre avec les petits cheveux
complètement pilotable pouvait gérer
tout ce que vous voulez c'est
hallucinant pareil tout est tactile ici
là ça doit être tactile aussi
voilà donc là je peux tout piloter ici
c'est hallucinant regardez-moi ça si ça
c'est pas du luxe
je sais pas ce que j'allais en faire un
petit tour maintenant à l'avant du
bateau
c'est vraiment très très longes pas si
j'ai acheté suivre j'ai presque le
vertige
on n'a pas accès à l'espace tout en haut
moss foie gras donc voilà ça c'est la
cabine du pilote
oui s'amuse et l'a donc là on a vu sur
la chambre et là vous avez de quoi vous
poser dans les petits coussins c'est
franchement franchement pas mal
[Musique]